now months of unrest in Hong Kong
erupted into violence at the city's
airport in the last week as police
clashed with pro-democracy protesters
barron happy with what they see as an
erosion of the freedoms they were
promised in 1997 when mainland China
took over what had been a British colony
so malcolm rifkind was the former
foreign secretary responsible for those
final stages of those handover
negotiations and he joins me now in
central London a very good morning to
you look in terms of the sign oh good
morning declaration that you helped
broker what do you make of what we're
seeing now what Britain's role should be
well it's 22 years since the handover
took place and of course Hong Kong
remains as it was intended to extremely
different from the rest of China it has
the rule of law it has free speech they
have access to the Internet people can
travel and live their lives in a
relatively normal way so in that sense
the agreement with China has held but
what the Chinese have been seeking to do
is gradually erode these freedoms and
the huge controversy over the
extradition bill was the latest example
of that so I have tremendous admiration
for the literally up to two million Hong
Kong people who came out onto the
streets and forced the Chinese
government to back down that was a few
weeks ago what's happening now is much
more disturbing and in terms of that
extradition bill we it's easy to
understand why people weren't happy
about it but but would that extradition
bill in your view actually have have
have broken the sino-british
relationship agreement yes absolutely so
I mean one of the points that was being
made by Carrie Lam the chief executive
was that the original agreement in 1997
it did not allow for extradition to
mainland China well of course it didn't
that was quite deliberate and it was
quite clear at the time the reason being
it's still valid is that China does not
have the rule of law it does not have
independent courts and if you allow
people to be extradited from Hong Kong
to China they disappear into a Chinese
equivalent of the gulag they have a
what's called a try
but it's nothing remotely comparable to
what is required to protect the
interests of the accused clearly these
protests have become stronger
particularly over the last week or so
and more violent as a result of all of
that we're now at a point out B where we
one would imagine pretty close to seeing
China wanting to intervene here what
impact would that actually have well
it'd be disasters for Hong Kong but it
would also be pretty disasters for China
because they're sending the People's
Liberation Army or tens of thousands of
the military into a Hong Kong is
infinitely more complicated than the
terrible events at Tiananmen Square a
long time ago
Tillman Square was a square one single
square although very large in the center
of Beijing it could be surrounded and
gradually taken under Chinese control
Hong Kong is a territory of seven
million people it's like a a small
country and after all they're
undoubtedly the Chinese could dominate
and destroy the current autonomy of Hong
Kong we could control the place in the
short term it wouldn't throw practical
purposes be like occupying a foreign
country because there would be a lot of
resistance there'd be a lot of civil
disobedience and that would continue for
quite a long time what then in your view
should or could Britain do to help ease
the tensions what we've been told we
heard from the Chinese ambassador to
London and other Chinese ministers
saying that there shouldn't be any as
they froze it foreign meddling in this
is there any movement for Britain here
the position of the United Kingdom is
quite different to all other countries
including the United States the whole
business of two systems in one country
was a treaty signed by the British
government and the Chinese government
that treaty has been deposited at the
United Nations we have a perfect right
if that treaty is being breached and to
make our concerns known in the most
robust way possible now I'm not being
unrealistic of course we cannot control
the events either in China or in Hong
Kong we don't have that kind of control
any longer but the idea that we have no
right to comment when China appears to
be Greek or contemplating and
massive breach of a treaty which we were
the co signatory to the Chinese are on
pretty rotten ground as they well know
if they make that kind of argument
you dealt obviously directly with the
Chinese 22 years ago sorting all of this
out the a very a nation who were going
to listen to any of those concerns
well they listen when it could affect
their own interests I mean I think there
is a balance here I think the Chinese
government were humiliated when they had
to climb down over the extradition bill
but of course what's happened since then
has involved many thousands of Hong Kong
people but not as many as protested
against the extradition bill taking the
stage one stage further now what I'd
like to see happen may be unrealistic
but what the Chinese government ought to
do is enter into a dialogue with the
people of Hong Kong about how to respect
more substantially the spirit and letter
of the two systems in one country
principle which was after all a Chinese
initiative under dong zhuo ping because
the alternative is the invasion I mean
they're not going to simply allow this
to continue indefinitely but if they
send in thousands of Chinese troops or
armed police then all the problems I
mentioned a few moments ago just begin
to happen it begins to get far worse and
of course it also makes the overriding
interest of trying to persuade the
people of Taiwan which effectively at
the moment is a separate country but
which they claim has to be seen as part
of China their whole argument to Taiwan
is why don't you follow Hong Kong two
systems in one country you could keep
your way of life while again becoming
part of China well that's never been
seen other than with huge skepticism in
Taiwan it would be for the birds
completely it's not already if you send
the People's Liberation Army over the
border into Hong Kong its malkin if I
may can I bring you a little bit closer
to home and what we're looking at over
the coming weeks and there's all this
talk there's been talk of a national
unity government Jeremy Corbyn being a
caretaker Prime Minister or perhaps
Kenneth Clark that would all need a
of no-confidence to be passed in in
Boris Johnson in effect do you think
that that will happen I think it might
happen because it doesn't need many on
the conservative side to either abstain
they don't have to vote against the
government they could abstain but it
only needs a small number and the
government are defeated and it seems
likely the numbers are there I think
it's important to be a quite specific
about what the issue is this is not a
clash about brexit as such it is a clash
about whether the government unable to
persuade Parliament and unwilling to
have a general election before october
31st are allowed to simply have their
way in a parliamentary democracy now
bricks it was all about bringing power
back to our Parliament and it's
perfectly legitimate for Boris Johnson
to say I think New Deal is in the public
interest that's the government's
judgment they have to persuade members
of parliament if they can persuade them
then there is a logjam how do you
resolve that logjam if you're a
parliamentary democracy you appeal
ultimately to the electorate through a
general election you can't have that
election after the date that you're
leaving the EU you have that election a
week 10 days whatever it is before that
date so either the government is
returned in which case it has a mandate
for the people for No Deal which I'm
sure the MPs would respect or if the
alternative is the case well then the
public of spectrum I mean there is an
argument to say is that neither that
legislation and primary legislation has
already been passed by the Commons to
say we are leaving on October the 31st
and and anything else is just seen as a
delaying tactic well it's not a delaying
tactic it is a question of judgment as
to whether No Deal is so painful so
damaging to the British economy to
British jobs in British prosperity and
I'm not offering a view on that at the
moment that's not what you're asking me
about but there is a dinner there are
huge numbers of people not just MPs who
believe it will be hugely damaging now
some of these people don't want breaks
it at all there are many others like
myself who accept a need for brexit but
say look it has to be with a deal not
with
some all the hard borders involved in in
leaving without one and remember if
you've been part of a organization like
the EU for 43 years that's almost half a
century and as a result of the internal
market you had completely free movement
of your exports your imports the same
health regulations no customs required
over half a century you can't just leave
all that literally in 24 hours and not
expect major disruption now if there was
no choice then there's no choice but
there is a choice and that's having it
forgive me Sir Malcolm but I mean you
you've been part of a very high-level
negotiations if you if you rule out no
deal as people are trying to do doesn't
that just simply weak of the negotiating
hand no I don't really I don't I don't
accept that I mean the EU does not
suffer as much from no deal remotely as
we do except for the Republic of Ireland
the Republic of Ireland will suffer as
much as the United Kingdom if there is
no deal every other country their trade
with the UK is important but it's
remember there's 27 countries in the EU
and the trade we do there almost half
our exports that go to the European
Union go to 27 different countries many
of these have relatively few exports to
the United Kingdom those that do have
and there is a surplus in trade wolf
suffer but not remotely as significantly
it's not half their total trade it's a
far smaller percentage so they've
already made clear they've done a deal
with Teresa mayors government the deal
was they didn't take three weeks to
negotiate it took two years so if if I'm
wrong if they are prepared to make
concessions I will say hallelujah the
Saints be praised but you know all the
evidence at the moment is that that is
not remotely likely as I suspect the
Prime Minister will find when he meets
mr. McRoy and Chancellor Merkel so
malcolm rifkind
appreciate your time today thank you
thank you